ncis's Michael Weatherly didn't
initially say why he left the show but
his real reason for leaving was
surprisingly romantic but not for the
reasons you might expect stars who have
been a part of the show have all had
their disparate reasons for leaving and
those reasons haven't always been
transparent from the start Polly
Perrette for example reportedly left
after a workplace situation that caused
her discomfort led to conflict between
her and Mark Harmon which wasn't
revealed at the time of her departure
Sasha Alexander who played Kate Todd
apparently felt the shooting schedule
was too difficult which makes sense
since the show's Infamous for long
shooting days her replacement Cody de
Pablo felt her character wasn't getting
enough respect and the script weren't
worthy of her as she revealed in a 2016
interview when Michael Weatherly left at
the end of the show's 13th season in
2016. it was an emotional ending given
that his character Tony dinoza was one
of the original NCIS agents and a major
lead in the series and going home
I see Tommy when Michael weatherly's
exit was announced no reason was given
for his departure although The Hollywood
Reporter linked the news to an incident
in which Weatherly pleaded no contest to
driving under the influence and was
sentenced to an alcohol recovery program
over the years however he's given a few
reasons for leaving when announcing his
new legal drama Bull he explained during
the television critics association's
press tour I was burnt out by NCIS and I
was ready for a new challenge he
explained that he was tired of the grind
saying it really felt like a circle that
had gone all the way around and I really
felt happy with the resolution of
character and my time on the show he
also told TV Insider that he was
experiencing Wanderlust and that there
were other things he wanted to do plus
he wished to spend time with his family
which includes his physician wife boyana
Yankovic their children and a son from
his previous marriage NCIS is well known
for its long hours actor Sean Murray
told Starry mag in 2020 that the average
workday was 12 hours for the actors
which was an improvement over previous
years as noted those hours drove
colleague Sasha Alexander away after
just two seasons so this wasn't
surprising whether Lee had after all
been on the show for 13 Seasons but
Michael Weatherly has also said he had
another reason for leaving one that was
more romantic it has everything to do
with the romance between his character
and Ziva
I did not want you to find me I'm
yet you did
there's sexual tension ignited in the
third season and continued its slow and
sometimes frustrating burn throughout
the seasons until Cody de Pablo
announced her departure and her
character was killed off except she
wasn't really dead Watchers of the show
know that DiNozzo later discovered that
he and Ziva had a child and when Tony
left it was to take care of their
daughter
well
thank God for the go bag right in the TV
Insider interview Weatherly noted that
he started thinking about leaving after
de Pablo left in ncis's 11th season the
reason he told the publication their
great Dynamic the bad nage and sparring
and flirting between those two
characters and how they would swing from
siblings to near lovers and back to
buddies that was gone and then I got to
the point where I felt I'd stayed at the
party for too long I would look around
the room and other people were really in
sync and having fun de Pablo has since
made several guest appearances on NCIS
revealing that Ziva had actually faked
her death she and DiNozzo were
apparently reunited in 2019 although
technically Weatherly hasn't been seen
on the series since he departed however
the actor posted a recent New Year's
tweet hinting that an on-screen reunion
might be coming in 2023 fans will want
to stay tuned
foreign